[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Good morning.
Welcome to Google I/O.
Computing is evolving again.
So we are focused
on driving the shift
and applying AI to
solving problems.
Today we are announcing a new
initiative called Google Lens.
Google Lens is a set of
vision-based computing
capabilities that can understand
what you're looking at
and help you take action
based on that information.
At Google, we are bringing
our AI efforts together
under Google.ai.
It's a collection of efforts
and teams focused on bringing
the benefits of AI to everyone.
SCOTT HUFFMAN: Last year at
I/O, we introduced the Google
Assistant, and today
I'm excited to announce
that the Google Assistant is
now available on the iPhone.
RISHI CHANDRA: We're
announcing support
for proactive assistance
coming to Google Home.
ANIL SABHARWAL: Suggested
sharing, shared libraries,
and photo books,
three new features
built from the ground up
with AI at their core.
SUSAN WOJCICKI:
The future of media
is a future of
openness and diversity.
DAVE BURKE: Seriously,
two billion active devices
is incredible.
STEPHANIE SAAD CUTHBERTSON:
I'm happy to announce
that we're making the first beta
release of O available today.
SAMEER SAMAT: I'm
excited to give you
a sneak peek into a
new experience we're
building for entry-level
Android devices.
Internally, we
call it Android Go.
CLAY BAVOR: VR and AR,
two different flavors
of what you might call
immersive computing, computing
that works more like we do.
SUNDAR PICHAI: It'll take
all of us working together
to bring the benefits of
technology to everyone.
That's our hope.
Let's do it together.
Thanks for your time today
and enjoy Google I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]